David can we get a few words
I think it's emotional for um for
everybody involved you know to obviously
um
the thing to be here to to you know to
celebrate the way we we have done with
everybody today I think it's been a it's
been a special day we were very lucky
you know we've we've been lucky as a
nation to have someone that has led us
the way her majesty has led us
um
for the amount of time with kindness
with caring and um and always
reassurance I think that's the one thing
that we all felt safe
um and we we will continue that with the
royal family but I think her majesty was
someone special and um and and will be
missed not just by by everyone in in our
country but um everyone around the world
Queen's young leaders program that must
have been such an honor it was you know
anytime you know throughout my career
I've been asked to do anything regarding
you know the the rural family Her
Majesty
um you know whether it's the the
princess or obviously our King now you
know I've always been obviously very
willing to do that because it's
something that you know I
I I grew up in a family that um were all
royalists and
um you know I said earlier that you know
today you know I think back to my
grandparents because if my grandparents
were alive they would have been here so
it's nice to be here to celebrate with
everybody you know the the life of her
majesty and and the Legacy that she's
left
you know there should always be respect
paid to to our Queen in in in in the
country in in this uh in this time of
mourning
um but speaking as a as a ex-football
player and the next England Captain you
know I know what it meant for us to step
out onto that field and to represent our
Queen and our country and and the Three
Lions and when we are out there it gives
us the opportunity to celebrate in a way
that only football can and the football
fans can but um
no I don't think I don't think